[Music]
tristan is with us tristan is in canton
ohio hi tristan welcome to the ramsay
show
hey mr ramsey how are you better than i
deserve sir how can george and i help so
i got a bit of a mouthful for you um i'm
22 years old i've about my girlfriend
and i've been dating for around six
years we're only boyfriend right now we
live in my mom's house and it's
currently like a night situation you
know nothing that's happening my
question is is that what's listening to
your show for the past month or so we
kind of realized how bad we are with our
finances and our debt
um about two years ago um i bought a
motorcycle and i currently around 22 000
on it and i also bought a truck about
four years ago at around eight thousand
dollars on it now me and my girlfriend
we wanna you know get engaged and uh buy
a house and say we'll save up for a
house here soon my question is that
should i sell a motorcycle
and break even on it and then just work
on paying off my truck or i've already
budgeted out monthly and i figured out
that i could pay off all 30 grand within
10 months but that's all i'm focusing
i'm not focusing on saving anything or
nothing okay what do you make
uh currently i have true jobs and i make
around sixty to seventy thousand
okay good for you you're working hard
i am thank you
okay so i i want to back up i got
confused on the details a little bit
okay so you are living with your
girlfriend
at your parents house
uh yes sir
okay
and y'all aren't married why
um because
we
we haven't gone that far well we want to
it's um
i'm buying a ring and we're going to
propose i've already got the blessing
from her dad and everything
she heard that she was living with her
parents and they left the state and she
wanted to stay here with me and she
didn't want to go get an apartment so i
finished my basement and she's living in
my basement
so you don't live in the same room
no sir okay i'm so okay i just i'm the
clarity on this is helpful thank you um
i'm sorry okay um
wow how much money do you have in the
bank
uh
right now i have around
three grand
okay is she working
uh she works two part-time jobs and i
would say probably annually she can
bring in
15 20.
is she in school
uh no sure how much do you see at home
mom uh she's 22. she's a stay-at-home
mom you have a kid no she no she wants
to be she doesn't want to go to college
or anything right now she's making money
on the side
oh actually okay
okay well if i'm in your shoes i'm
selling the motorcycle i'm getting a
ring i'm getting married and moving
forward with our life because i think
she's more important than the motorcycle
would you agree
i would agree oh yeah you didn't have a
choice on that answer brother it was a
trick i completely trapped you yeah you
were dead
here's the thing here's the thing she
actually i'm the one who's wanting to
sell the motorcycle
she
does not want me to sell it yeah that's
sweet that's sweet and all but it's dumb
you need to sell a motorcycle yeah um
okay
so what's what's your household income
for the year
67 60 70 years a thousand this feels
like a lot of motorcycle and trucks
being 60 70. and your your truck is how
much is your truck worth uh i owe about
well it's worth around 15 by around
eight on it okay good good yeah let's
get rid of the motorcycle wait a minute
you have a
you you have a 22 000 motorcycle
yes sir
oh we're definitely selling the
motorcycle yeah
okay what's the payment on that
uh 440 a month yeah
that's a sweet bike what is it
uh it's a 2020 harley-davidson fat boy
30-year anniversary
that's a beast
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm sorry i was a
smart aleck but you still got to sell it
oh my gosh oh that's a wonderful bike
but yeah it's completely out of school
here it's the it's the thing that sticks
out in your whole story is the dumbest
thing in the whole story the rest of the
story that's what i tell everyone the
rest of your story is a pretty good
story i mean you got a good situation
going on you're being very moral and
very right
you ask her dad for his blessing he gave
it which means you're a good guy
um man i'm just i think there's a whole
lot good going on with you yeah the
motorcycle is just the dumbest thing in
the picture yeah get rid of it i love it
though it's awesome i'm sorry you'll get
you another bike though you'll get you
another bike i mean someday you'll get a
bike and you'll own the bike this time
and it won't own you
yeah just listen to your show we've kind
of just realized how dumb we are with
everything no you're not dumb i mean
really overall you've done a good job
it's just that's the one thing that's
sticking out big time
so then then you only got eight thousand
dollars in a couple months you're
debt-free and you don't need to buy a
house you just go wrench an apartment
and you guys get married
okay
i think she needs to find some some work
she enjoys doing yeah it's fine if one
day she starts developing a career even
if uh even if she does choose to come
and just be a full-time mom after babies
come and all that but if i were you
i i would work diligently to uh be
out of the car debt and out of your
mom's house and married by fall
okay
and i think you can do that
i think i can too okay
we believe in you yeah and of course the
motorcycle's gone and you started your
life i mean you know when i was 22
sharon and i were married we live in a
one-bedroom apartment we had two junky
little cars and we started off our life
and we were dumber than a rock we were a
lot dumber than you tristan i mean we
really were
um i mean if you looked at our finances
they were horrible
and you know and i just expanded that
horrible and made it you know with
millions and it was horrible and then i
went broke and lost everything because i
expanded my stupidity so kristen you
really got a good start yeah you really
it's a reversible decision it was a cool
thing to dig into your story though and
start to understand what all was going
on there because at first it sounded
like it's one thing and then i got a
whole nother definitely a strange
situation not the norm you got to learn
a little bit about what's happening
there